good evening welcome to a special
edition of tucker carlson tonight
you probably didn't see it live not many
people did
but last month a former republican
member of congress called susan molinari
spoke at the democratic national
convention
if you thought about it it was an odd
moment susan manari is a very nice
person
actually people who know her like her
but it wasn't really clear what she was
doing
speaking at the democratic convention
most democratic voters probably never
have heard of susan molinari
and her whole speech lasted just a
moment so what was the point of it
exactly well here's the point susan
molinari was a top lobbyist for google
she was a senior executive at google
until 2018
she wasn't at the dnc to speak to anyone
watching from home on tv
she was speaking to the democratic party
itself her message to them was very
clear
silicon valley is on your side will help
you win this thing
by inviting susan molinari democrats
also sent a message back
to silicon valley you have nothing to
fear from us
elect joe biden and you can keep your
monopolies you can extend your control
over american life
this was a bargain a long time in the
making immediately after donald
trump was elected in 2016 executives at
google held a company-wide meeting
really it was more of a group therapy
session
the company's chief financial officer
ruth porat broke down in tears as she
spoke
she asked how google could quote use the
great strength and resources
and reach we have to continue to advance
really
important values end quote what are
those values
they're not your values google
co-founder sergey brin was also
devastated by trump's victory he found
the election quote
deeply offensive watch brynn go full
encounter group
in front of his employees most
people here are pretty upset
and pretty sad for uh
because of the election as an immigrant
and a refugee
i certainly find this election
deeply offensive is there anything
positive you see from this election
result
[Music]
boy that's that's a really tough one
right now
um another oppressed billionaire at the
same meeting brian suggested that google
change its
algorithm the very core of its search
business to promote quote
better quality of governance and
decision making
what does that mean in other words they
want to subvert democracy and everyone
in the room knew exactly what he was
saying and they got to work doing it
two years later video of that
company-wide meeting leaked any other
company would have been ashamed of it
the head of america's most powerful
corporation
caught on camera planning to manipulate
voting in elections but google was not
embarrassed they didn't stop either no
one made them stop so they continued
last year a new video emerged this video
showed a woman called gen
gennady who works in the artificial
intelligence unit at google
confessing to trying to manipulate the
2020 election the one underway now
janai said quote we all got screwed over
in 2016. so we're rapidly been like
what happened there and how do we
prevent it from happening
again once again she's speaking
about the results of a free and fair
democratic election
that google the most powerful company in
the world didn't like so they're trying
to make sure it never happens again
it's brazen but they're doing it
why are they doing it well imagine
you're them imagine we're back in 2016
and you're a tech executive in northern
california you're in your 30s you're not
particularly impressive though you have
all the right credentials
and yet somehow you are now worth
hundreds of billions of dollars
and you look on as donald trump wins the
white house he's running on the most
populous republican platform since teddy
roosevelt
on the other side openly socialist
candidates are elected to congress
people are tired of oligarchs like you
you have not improved america you know
this could be very bad for you
someone might tax your stock options or
seize your private island so what do you
do next
well silicon valley had a few ideas
first they boosted democrats who were
aligned with wall street
and multi-billion dollar companies like
theirs as long as people were distracted
by identity politics as long as they
were fighting about unresolvable issues
like race and gender
you might be able to distract them long
enough that you could pull this off
you won't talk about the fact that you
don't pay taxes
if you're busy attacking cops and other
powerless members of the working class
so there's a reason kamala harris and
joe biden are now
the standard bearers of the democratic
party it's not because democratic voters
love them so much they didn't
it's because they're compliant joe biden
has trouble formulating sentences
clearly he's not posing a threat to tech
monopolies of course not after 50 years
of
shilling for corporations and no
politician has demonstrated more clearly
her ability to use race tension to
divide this country more effectively
than kamala harris has kamal harris has
applauded the riots
watch i want to make clear that i know
that there are protests still happening
in major cities across the united states
i'm just not seeing the reporting on it
that i that i had that's right
for the first few weeks um but they're
not they're not going to stop and that's
they're not this is a movement i'm
telling you they're not going to stop
before election day in november and
they're not going to stop
after election day and that should be
everyone should take note of that
on both levels that this isn't they're
not going to let up and they should not
the writers aren't going to let up and
they should not says kamala harris
right this is the same conley harris who
tweeted that michael brown was murdered
by cops in ferguson missouri
he wasn't murdered that's not
speculation barack obama's own justice
department
concluded he wasn't murdered that's a
lie but harris repeated it anyway and
her allies at twitter allowed her to
disseminate that line nationwide
they didn't pull that tweet down so
silicon valley is doing all it can to
help the biden harris ticket
and this is just the beginning this year
for example linkedin founder reid
hoffman and other billionaires
through major financial support behind
an organization called
acronym reportedly acronym has set up
bogus
news sites and swing states to portray
democrats in a positive life
oh kind of like the propaganda they
claimed russia was propagating
in the last election right this is the
party that loves to complain about the
death
of local journalism but they are funding
a propaganda network
to change people's opinions before an
election and the goal of course isn't
just to make democrats look good
it's to make you terrified because
scared populations are easier to control
that's why facebook blocked a video
featuring the president pointing out an
obvious scientific truth
and no scientist disagrees with this
children are mostly not at risk from the
effects of the coronavirus
according to the scientific journal the
lancet the virus is quote
generally a mild disease in children
including infants
fatal outcomes are quote rare if you
knew that
you might have real questions about the
lockdowns joe biden and the teachers
unions and so many other institutions in
this country are pushing
so you can't know it facebook decided
you should not be able to see
those data from the lancet twitter went
a step further
and had their 27 year old liberal arts
majors lock down the president's
campaign account
until the campaign deleted video of
themselves
video themselves in other words
kiss the ring said twitter we won't just
erase the video we need you to
bow publicly to our authority and do it
yourself
this has implications far beyond the
election far beyond who
becomes president in january
this is about how much power the tech
monopolies
will have it's about how much power the
professional class can continue to wield
as the middle class
dies technology executives in san
francisco are the product
of those institutions of left-wing
universities they've been trained
to dislike the country that made their
success possible and they very much
do so anything they do that can
weaken social cohesion in this country
or trust in our institutions is of
course
appealing and that includes pushing
mail-in voting which everyone knows
about
voter fraud that's why big tech is
pushing that it's why they're backing
radical
politicians and da's like chessy boudin
in san francisco people like that
degrade and destabilize
our country but silicon valley is in
favor of that and has been in favor of
that
since 2016.